we unleashed something powerful that
could destroy the world I need your help
Scott we got this you know
I'm an Avenger now yes so you've
mentioned great job back there are you
gonna say the same thing to me
good job thank you I have wings why
would I go low no I know that I just
want to make sure that these guys do
antenna the wasp July 6 we unleashed
something powerful we call her the ghost
she could destroy the world I'd love to
help you I'm under house arrest we'll
have you home by lunch I'm gonna come
with you guys and watch the team enough
[Music]
hang on
great job back there thankfully gonna
say the same thing to me good job thank
you
so how long have you been ant-man again
no uh I just sort of happened it's like
bad guys like you
[Music]
and I seem to mess it up almost every
time
[Applause]
maybe you just need someone watch her
back
like a partner
[Music]
dr. Pam I actually heard what happened
to you you open up the quantum realm
that's when he's crazy could be gold so
that walks two walls to stuff
slowly tech now supposed to take over
the world or whatever who would have
believed that in your hour of need you
would turn the house at me because we
robbed you do you remember that's us
feeling chess you've got this
and man and the wasp teaming up follow
my lead
[Music]
she seems more intense
[Music]
you go low I'll go high I have wings why
would I go low
hey what'd I miss we were just tiny I
was partners with Hank on a project
called Goliath how big did you get my
record 21 feet you 65 feet 65 if you to
our flesh comparing sizes 65
[Music]